el valle de georges cerca de sant tiene
todos los ingredientes de un pequeño
paraíso agrícola sin embargo el día a
día es un infierno para algunas personas
las empresas de seguridad patrulla en
los huertos día y noche para proteger el
oro verde de la región
los aguacates atraen el crimen
organizado pero también los marañones
las nueces de macadamia o la madera
algunos agricultores de limpopo han
perdido hasta el 20 por ciento de sus
ingresos en los últimos dos años cada
granja tiene su propio escenario
están realmente decididos a robar los
aguacates
ciudades
una vez que identifican nuestra granja
incluso si hay una cerca encontrarán una
manera de entrar
andor encima por debajo lograrán entrar
están realmente decididos y jamás es
difícil decir cuánto pueden robar
depende del tamaño del grupo de la forma
en que se organicen del tipo de
transporte que tengan pero robar una
tonelada en una noche es bastante común
pueden ser hasta 4 toneladas por noche
les mentiría si dijera que esto es
exactamente lo que hemos perdido todo lo
que puedo decir es que parece que se ha
convertido en algo normal degustar robar
es algo cotidiano por aquí
con más de 15.000 hectáreas de huertos
sudáfrica es uno de los mayores
productores de aguacate
pero tres cuartas partes de los
agricultores de estas regiones dicen
tener problemas de robos los aguacates
robados se venden fácilmente en el
mercado local
nadie tiene cómo distinguir un aguacate
de otro
ian y sus amigos no tienen forma de
reconocer los aguacates que se plantan
en su propiedad
la gente ha intentado marcar la fruta
rociándola con un producto que contiene
un identificador microscópico esa es la
mejor manera de demostrar que la fruta
es suya pero de nuevo dados los enormes
volúmenes que tenemos no creo que
alguien pueda utilizar ese tipo de
método main street' práctico
simplemente cuando se recogen los
aguacates ya es demasiado tarde así que
los agricultores se atrincheran como su
propiedad de 45 hectáreas está equipada
con un sistema de alarma incorporado y
ya no puede reaccionar muy rápidamente
sandy y su vecino que dirige su nueva
granja desde hace 6 meses ha librado la
misma batalla cultiva 9 macadamia un
bien aún más preciado que el aguacate
aquí están nuestros frutos secos 3
dólares el kilo eso es mucho dinero para
muchos de los presentes estas son
pequeñas pepitas de oro y nos quitan el
sueño imagínense toda la temporada con
lluvia poniendo los abonos organizando
el riego pagando a los empleados y justo
cuando recibes los frutos de tu trabajo
viene alguien y se lo lleva
de los árboles o de nuestros y el modus
operandi y las empresas de seguridad lo
conocen esta empresa es la más pequeña
de las empresas de seguridad privada de
sanín
sin embargo marius el jefe tiene 230
empleados encontramos 6 bolsas llenas
afuera entre las bananeras ahí es donde
se escondían para esperar a que pasaran
los guardias en el momento en que pase
ahí es cuando entran entrar a recoger
recoger de recoger y fue donde
encontramos seis bolsas llenas justo
afuera de la plantación de bananos quien
encuentre una bolsa encontrará a otras
los ladrones se apoderan de frutos y
nueces en un promedio de una hectárea
por hora los camiones se llenan por la
noche estas fotos muestran que es muy
complicado detener la hemorragia a mil
euros la tonelada de aguacate siempre
habrá candidatos para esconderse en
estas propiedades
el 95% de los chicos nos dicen que roban
porque no tienen trabajo
y eso es dinero fácil con corta es una
cerca llenas unas cuantas de bolsas
activadas de atún y con los que son
atrapados con las manos en la masa' no
arriesgan mucho en el tribunal de sun en
el robo de fruta es difícil de probar y
rara vez se castiga los agricultores
quieren que se localice a los
patrocinadores y que las autoridades se
tomen más en serio estos robos la
magnitud del fenómeno preocupa a los
profesionales del sector que hablan de
delincuencia organizada
para este experto está relacionado con
el aumento de la demanda los precios del
aguacate y los marañones en el mercado
internacional
las cosas no siempre han sido tan buenas
financieramente como ahora pero eso no
significa que dentro de nueve o diez
años
el negocio siga igual de rentable hay
ciclos hay que pensar a largo plazo y si
los precios caen las pérdidas generadas
por esos robos podrían amenazar la
rentabilidad de algunas propiedades si
los agricultores asumen sus pérdidas hoy
no lo harán para siempre
uno de nuestros clientes álex palmer
cultiva aguacates y leches ahora viven
pero dejó el país hace dos meses el robo
de aguacates también está aumentando las
explotaciones de méxico nueva zelanda y
españa sudáfrica tendrá que inspirarse
en el resto del mundo para luchar contra
esta nueva plaga